i love all these comments about how
rosie kept my life normal
no offense rob mom
no
that never happened
bye bye what do you mean i didn't do
anything normal i did normal things
i'm normal
i'm totally normal
jeez viv
i'm gonna tell some secrets about you
rosie o'donnell jokingly claps back at
her own daughter vivian for saying she
didn't have a normal upbringing she just
was really like
didn't inform us for really anything
yeah and it all unfolded on tick-tock
let's go back to the beginning
it's all a response to fans reacting to
a video the 19 year old made where she
talked about a mysterious woman who used
to come to her birthday parties so yeah
this beautiful lady mo would always come
to our house and come to all of our
birthday parties
and bring our kids over to for little
playdates and stuff and
i just never had any idea who the she
was one night i was watching tv with ro
and um
we were probably watching like an award
show or something anyways
it's mo get an
award and then i'm like wait
moe is madonna yeah madonna no biggie
she's rosie's longtime friend and a
league of their own co-star little bat
hit me right in the head bam really yep
your head's not your behind cause that
looks really swollen
hey what the heck i had no idea was
madonna
until i was uh
yeah like 12. so fans hit up the comment
section praising rosie for keeping life
relatively normal for viv which brings
us back to she just um
was really like
didn't inform us for really anything
i think that was more it because once i
would find out she'd be like vivi come
on you know that she has done
so much for me and i am so incredibly
incredibly thankful for her
but one thing she has not done
is normal
and it didn't take long for her mama to
chime in about it bye bye what do you
mean i didn't do anything normal
i did normal things
i'm normal
i'm totally normal
geez viv
i'm going to tell some secrets about you
yeah the clapback was all in fun i think
it's important that we do family things
together and we will continue to
probably forever and while growing up
the daughter of a famous parent
definitely isn't the norm keeping family
close has always been a big deal to
rosie who has four more kids and rule
number one in her house honesty is the
best policy well i always think the best
thing to do with kids is tell the truth
you know and then i'm like wait
moe is madonna even if you don't always
explain a superstar is your best friend
there's no discussion of feeling that is
uh
you know not acceptable in our house and
whatever you think and feel and question
you have you get answered and that's
sort of the way i did it and it seems to
be working
[Music]
you